le quartier des carmes à orléans compte
60 immeubles vétustes dont celui ci loué
par une famille de six personnes
franchement les autres entre l'hiver
l'acquitté arrive le froid désolation et
les bêtes ce qui est quelqu'un phares
les cafards cessé sur le fait qu'il va
fermer tous les bâtiments bas les
cafards venez ça veut dire que j'ai ici
chercher la chaleur au niveau maurras
web marchands de sommeil et
propriétaires indélicats ont fini par
faire la mauvaise réputation du secteur
la municipalité d'orléans a elle décidé
d'employer les grands moyens
le principe du bâton et de la carotte
c'est à dire vous avez l'incitation qui
va très loin au niveau des subventions
puisque aujourd'hui c'est 14 sont 14
millions qui sont mis sur la table pour
aider les propriétaires mais en même
temps à partir du moment où les
propriétaires ne remplissent pas leurs
devoirs et notamment pour louer des
logements insalubres à des personnes qui
n'ont souvent pas d'autre choix que de
faire appel à ces personnes là dans le
domaine privé
eh bien il est normal d'intervenir de
façon coercitive et faire preuve aussi
d'un intérêt manifeste et parfois même
de l'abandon de la propriété par les
propriétaires cela fait dix ans que le
quartier des carmes eux fait face aux
problèmes d'insalubrité
un dossier qui fut compliqué mais
aujourd'hui approuvée par tous c'est une
très bonne chose
je pense qu'on peut tous s'en satisfaire
ce que je voudrais ajouter c'est que ces
questions salubrité ne sont pas propres
quartiers carmel existe dans tout centre
ancien et que une fois qu'on aura mené à
bien l'opération sur les carmes
je prends ce sera nécessaire de
l'élargir ensuite au quartier bourgogne
qui souffre en fait des mêmes
difficultés
une politique qui agit sur de multiples
propriétaires privés et qui prend du
temps